Shawn Salisbury set to join us morning
drive host is Sports Talk 790 in Houston
and could have Shawn back on the program
Shawn I'm concerned for deshaun Watson
should I be for his safety yeah you
should Dan you know when I always tell
people when you're they always talk
about quarterback wide receiver
you know the mess that you need in the
continuity you need but there's no more
important continuity in sports not
pitcher catcher quarterback wide
receiver than those five guys up front
and adding tonsils big but you can tell
with a week how much you did a week to
prepare us all and then the
communication you know it's the line
stunts and it's okay you got that guy I
got that guy and eventually you're gonna
see Titus Howard Mack sharping two
rookies play and then you're gonna have
to move Howard who is normal positions
and outside left tackle they're trying
to play him a guard possibly to the
other side and the right side so it's
gonna be interchanged in a lot you can't
take that many hit stand it's sax or one
thing but the constant hits after the
throw and the guys got guts
you know Watson's gonna hang in there
but it doesn't matter who it is
eventually like a quarterbacks arm only
has so many throws so many hits this
guy's got DNA that says championship MVP
but the availability of him if this
keeps up it's not going to last because
you can't continue to ask him to do this
and during the season damn it's so tough
to get guys up to date because you're
putting game plans in so mechanics and
work in the communication the best lines
we have or the lines that have been
together a while it's going to take a
bit deshaun Watson better have a better
have a suit of armor this year because
he is going to take his hit as you saw
on Monday night and he holds on to the
ball a little too long and this is
something that young quarterbacks learn
you certainly learned it you just you
know you take your loss it's a small
loss and that is I threw it away and
then you come back for another play
instead of holding on to it and that's
another thing that stood out also JJ
Watt I can't remember watching a game
where JJ Watt was non-threatening agreed
we're going on well I think I'm free
real quick on the Watson thing dan you
make a great point I said
on my show and long said for the last
couple years it's that hero syndrome for
a great quarterback you don't want to
take that guts away but sometimes the
best play on the field is a thought to
your mom or your dad in the stands and
then tee it up to live another down
because I love the fact that he wants to
make every play but watch the great ones
they hit singles and if the singles
aren't there throw it away give me seven
yards on second down and now I remember
one time I held the ball too long it was
like sex third and 14 and Brian Billick
in Minnesota pointed at me and I thought
well what's the next play he pointed to
me again
meaning you got this call dude I ain't
got my playbook for third and 14 so you
don't want to do that so he that's the
only weakness he has and Dan with what
well I know people complained about
clowny in Houston he was still a
presence a dominant run presence and
while jayjay every time we questioned
him he steps his game up but Dan the
only time they called his name was in
pregame warmup I mean when we told me it
talk to you introduce you yeah that's
that's never had that doesn't happen so
I would expect him to come out a little
angry against you know Gardner Minshew
in Jacksonville but you step older more
surgeries and you may not have to double
him as much as you used to and they
don't have unless merciless steps his
game up the other presence to say okay
stop that guy and then JJ can be free
it's gonna be difficult you probably
won't see that stat line again from him
but I'm not sure he's the Khalil Mac Von
Miller guys but when you do question him
he finds a way to step his game but
they're gonna need him because that
defense was putrid
on Monday night what else still down
from week one for you I was really
really the obvious about the Cleveland
Browns but Dan not just disappointing
the way that they know that they lost
and I went back and look at the fourth
quarter there was 22 to 13 going into
the fourth quarter at home with all this
hype and I'm a Browns believer I've told
you I think they're gonna make the
playoffs but when you're down nine at
home the disappointing part was you ran
away and hidden in in the fourth quarter
and gave up 21 more points to a
Tennessee Titans team that looks better
than we thought and if Mariota can stay
healthy that disappointed me I was at I
know the Dolphins and the rest of that
they're going to go away
really impressed with the Cowboys in the
way dak Prescott played but I'd say the
biggest one for me was the defense for
the Texans because we're right here but
was no question the way the Browns not
just showed up but the way they even
still in the game in the fourth quarter
gave up 21 points for a playoff team you
can't do that and probably how poor the
Pittsburgh Steelers offense looked
against the New England Patriots I mean
holding bend to that and holding that
offense to you're not going to land
score a touchdown that was dominant it's
the best Patriots team I've seen in a
decade know and I didn't pick them for
the Super Bowl because I wasn't sure
about the offensive line but I should
have been ok with the offensive line
somehow somehow they don't have linemen
who could start for other teams but they
can protect Tom Brady how does that
happen Dan - twofold one is Tom Brady
pre-snap gives you he knows where he's
going to deliver the ball most time
before the ball snapped because of his
preparation in the years he's been in it
which also gives the offensive line an
idea with their communication so the
ball because the ball comes out so
quickly you remember when Moreno played
you and I have talked about this in past
years he went dan the ball was out so
quickly even when they had a free runner
they didn't get to him and they didn't
get to hit him and now they protect him
but also Dan coaching and teaching
matters the ability to get guys to
process information quickly Dantes
Carnegie is as good as we have if we had
Hall of Fame for assistant coaches the
guy's long up there with Hudson Houck
you know within his days with the
Cowboys as far as guys that know how to
teach it coaching anybody can yell and
scream can you teach it and get a guy on
Thursday and Friday to process it go out
through your walk through Saturday and
then put it together on Sunday so but
they've been doing this with all kinds
of guys not just offensive line back up
tight in a running back a slot guy a
defensive back they may be a plug in
play but the teaching part of its a big
part of it and that's why no matter what
the name is or what the jersey number is
the New England Patriots will always
protect their quarterback and he gives
him that chance because he does not hold
the ball he knows were delivered on time
talking to Sean salisbury morning drive
host sports talk 790 in Houston former
analyst at the mother
former NFL quarterback what do you think
the Commissioner of the NFL should do
with Antonio Brown leading into this
weekend if anything dad I think he's got
a you know we're such a rush to judgment
instant you know got to do this now he's
done some turd things Antonio Brown you
know there with his teammates and
leaving him hanging in Pittsburgh and
Oakland I mean not even talking about
this this information we got last night
about a lawsuit all the other stuff
makes him a guy when they say always a
great teammate well great teammates
don't leave guys hanging they just don't
leave teammates hanging on the eve of a
football season so that's one now the
other side of it is you've got we got to
let due process take over I don't I
don't know I wasn't there we've had he
said she said the victim obviously
deserves the respect to be heard as does
Antonio Brown I personally don't think
the Patriots need him you got more of a
chance at risk with him than you do
reward now and it's gotten to the point
as great as he is I always say is it
worth the migraine I'm not sure he's
worth a migraine he's going to the right
place to give you the proper medicine
for the migraine and Bill Belichick but
the Commissioner the one thing you
always got to do in my mind for women
and children dan even you got to be
honorable and fair to Antonio Brown he
deserves it but you've got to err on the
side of caution instead of apologize to
me after issuing a punishment whether it
be right or wrong you've got to do the
right you got to do the due diligence
and then make the decision and right now
on a civil lawsuit Antonio Brown
nothing's been proven I fully expect him
to be in practice and I fully expect him
to be in uniform unless of course the
Patriots say wait a minute
the optics of this doesn't look or sound
right we're going to hold off on this a
bit but you know what until the
Commissioner proves to me I can trust
he's going to make the right decision
I'm gonna withhold judgment until he
gets all the facts and that's what we
all should do because we all rush to it
way too soon we've done it in the past
and been wrong and at times right I'm
not willing to take that risk until I
know what's going on with Antonia Brown
but I don't consider him a great
teammate great talent but a pain in the
rear end or migraine headache that I'm
not sure the Patriots need regardless of
how good he is I'll leave you with this
with the quarterback next man up
and dak Prescott is gonna I guess
eventually be the highest-paid player in
the NFL at what point does that streak
end of next quarter backup is the
highest paid quarterback it's not ending
anytime soon Dan I mean if you if Brady
wanted to he should go to them and say
you guys gonna pay me 50 million for
every year I play because he could he's
worth it
he's got the rings to show it but
Watson's coming down the pike it's gonna
be in the hunt so he'll make more than
that he's gonna make for you that's
gonna make 35 36
Watson's gonna come along and make close
to 40 mahomes makes and Mullins is gonna
make 42 40 we're looking at Dan five
years two hundred million dollars we're
starting now
well what about Mitchell drew Biscay is
Mitchell true Biscay gonna be the
highest-paid quarterback that's well now
with my Holmes and Watson they're in
that same year category unless true
Biscay has a a watson flag because look
at Watson's numbers I mean the first
three years I mean it's been phenomenal
rushing and three and yards I mean he's
been phenomenal he's in rarefied air
been mahomes now for Biscay goes those
50 touchdowns yeah he's gonna get it Dan
even though cuz we're not paying on
seven years production we're paying on
potential but right now no true Biscay
is not going to make that but we got
Jacoby percent making 15 million a year
and he's gonna back up so yeah true
Biscay is gonna get paid if they
consider him somewhat a franchise but
mahomes and watson are gonna break the
back sooner than later good to catch up
with you bud we appreciate it Sean great
to catch up with you and great stuff on
Sports Center it was really nice to see
it man it would tugged at the
heartstrings you guys were awesome it
was great thanks for a Thank You Sean
Sean Salzburg morning drive host Sports
Talk 790 in Houston for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]